the way they did it is actually super
simple it is just timer mapping
I'm sorry though man I'm sorry because
it's all 100 natural and it feels
incredible to watch kinda Jordan can I
just show you what a nice explosion
I would be honest
thanks to Bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out how to get 25 off of each pair
of bessies
hey guys welcome back to VFX artist
react today we are joined by Nico and
Jordan hello we've seen in such hits as
slightly offensive bowling animations
today's Avengers episode for me it's I I
just needed a cathartic release you're
eager to show your teeth yeah yeah I do
have one thing I'm very passionate about
I'm a very passionate about not liking
it
so I wanted to start by kind of setting
the tone here right explosions are very
complex to create they take a lot of
time a lot of iterations a ton of
artistry hey are you talking about in
real life well this first example is 100
in-camera special effects it actually
set the world record for the largest
film explosion that still stands today I
believe really 2 000 gallons inspector
dude what a shot pretty cool right no it
let's go let's go
oh yeah
oh
I mean that's pretty big that's pretty
big right immediately you know when
you're watching this the sense of scale
is just inherent right you see how slow
and like undulating these big explosions
are you get the emissive lighting kind
of casting down on the ground you get
incredibly Dynamic difference in the
evolution of the smoke and the fire the
color differences and the smoke and the
way it diffuses and blurs over time like
this is what you aim for when you're
doing CG explosions this is the
evolution you want again because it's
all 100 natural so you're seeing that
and it feels incredible to watch kinda
2
000 gallons of gasoline is not enough
what is it that's lacking here is it
just not a big enough I don't know it
feels like a pillow fight kinda you
agree
I'm not trying to say I like I'm
underwhelmed this incredible Artistry
and planning that goes into this but I
don't see this and go like oh that's
dangerous you know because it's because
they're so far away they're so far away
everyone's so chill there's like no
debris every time you see like real life
something this big blowing up it's like
get the F down oh my God how do they
walk away in movies without flexing when
it explodes behind them there's no way
you know what I'm saying they're so
nonchalant about it that it kind of like
rubs off on me Jordan can I just show
you what a nice movie
I would be honored see I want to know
what a what a Nico like certified
explosion looks like like I promised I
would stop dunking right I promise I
never done again really at least of all
friends on the couch next to me but type
in Blown Away ending
he's bad
he's blown away
oh see yes okay yeah you feel a lot
closer to it
you better buckle up if I get blown away
yeah you feel it
dude just hard shock waves this is what
James Bond and that lady should have
been doing yeah that's really good yeah
until it was done no that that one I
mean again like the same examples exist
in this of course with the added debris
and like that cool man that shift of
weight and energy as it kind of pulsates
through the rest of the smoke like it's
so Dynamic and it feels so dangerous it
feels super dangerous like you can see
the world like just like Echo yeah is
that camera shake like practical It's
gotta be I mean like kind of feels it
right is it like the camera actually
just going from the shock wave or is
that you can travel along the water
that's definitely real is the deeper
getting concussed yeah yeah yeah it's
late you want camera Shake reference
here's camera Shake reference see this
is what I'm talking about yeah I think
is the camera Shake it's debris it's
camera Shake it's showing like the
concussion some force it all just starts
with this pressure and the shock wave
and how that like affects things around
it that's for me my like cue this is
great and it makes you feel all sorts of
good things what if I were to strip away
all those good things would you want to
watch it yes let me hear deep into the
void I'd like to show you something from
Skyfall that made me go
what do you what are you laughing at you
when you see it when you see it you
won't unsee it
how does it make you feel though like
it's the same feeling as the last James
Bond shot where it's like oh something's
blowing up over there yeah
like it's that same sensation you know
they got more particles they got more
stuff feels very like unmarried in the
scenes color grade the black levels I
think are one part of it like if you
look at the dark areas of the building
they're like definitely bumped up
compared to the Blackness of the smoke
yeah it feels very composited it just
feels like very composite it might not I
think it's like it could be a model it
could be like very much not composited
in how you think but the way they color
graded it just pushed it so far the
biggest thing that pulled me out is when
you see it you can't not see it the
debris watch the second wave appear the
second wave appears as if from the void
I'm spending all my time looking at the
fire yep the debris it just doesn't feel
like that's from the building and it's
because obviously you can't blow up you
know MI6 yeah I'm sure they'll blow it
up they have to do a CG version or
create a miniature yeah or just use
stock stock footage and this the debris
especially smells stocky to me oh yeah
and there's no light being cast on the
building at all there's nothing that
makes it feel like a part of the same
shot and like all these things stack
together just really kind of pull you
out of it in contrast to something
that's completely obviously organic in
camera if you can't tell we're super
passionate about explosions and tomorrow
we have a video coming out we actually
talk about CGI explosions versus the
real thing we dunk on CGI explosions a
little bit because they just they fall
short so often and want to show why we
want to show what makes real explosions
so great and it's not to say this that
all CGI explosions are bad there's some
awesome ones but it's gonna be a sweet
video it's gonna have lots of explosions
in it subscribe or come back to this
channel tomorrow last one you guys have
reviewed this before but I don't think
you've reviewed the explosion part of it
oh right it's back is this the tiny
explosion
okay let's watch that tiny explosion
no
oh
man oh wait you can't even prank this is
a prank it's so beautiful it's the most
beautiful moment let's can we just see
that little boy there it is there he is
right there you blink and they grow up
you know
we wash this already but we cut the
little tiny explosion scene I don't know
why so this this is Rife with issues
obviously yeah and it's fair because
this is a click and drag massive
explosion asset that was scaled down to
fit into Steel
I did oh my gosh yeah here it is yeah
where is it oh
that's gonna do back in there yeah he's
embarrassed you know
yeah his IMDb is just this one movie so
this this is kind of in my opinion is
everything that's wrong with when you
don't use real explosions because
obviously when she hits it there's an
initial like explosive force and it is
moving so slow this is an expansive
explosion that is blowing her back and
it's unfolding slower than she's moving
one of the most egregious Parts is we
enter slow motion right to feel the
significance of this blast but the
Embers continue to move at normal speed
wait what they just continue to fly oh
you're right they're just fly and fly
around they're free there's a reason for
why that explosion is so small it's
because in the story she's supposed to
live okay and she's supposed to be
thrown back by it so if the explosion
somehow is any bigger than that little
boy if you cast any other explosion
other than little boy it means like
instant death for that character and so
they need the smallest little explosion
to show that like oh oh she's just got
knocked back from it not like completely
enveloped little boy is actually a
pretty Iraq name for an explosion
considering that's the name like the
first nuke yeah it was yeah yeah yeah
have you seen the stealth explosion I
have not yeah okay but I'd love to sing
again
how could you have seen it half you
probably haven't if you haven't watched
it just sit back and enjoy
[Music]
whoa yeah my mind oh my gosh it makes my
heart beat faster holy crap oh my God oh
my gosh and just the Jinx and he's just
like yeah let's get out of
it let's do it I forgive it
the way the fuel explodes and then like
ignites and just everybody goes lifting
up with the burning problems shooting
through the middle yeah the fact is like
a wall of fire and then the cars come
out of it oh gosh and you can see how
all the cars are just like pipes with
like cloths they're like PVC with like
tape together yeah yeah and it's just
like this like haze around the explosion
too of just like unburnt Fuel and dust
you just feel like the Breath of Life
goes yeah when it comes to a big fiery
explosion and someone going
like like this I mean I feel I'm getting
better vibes from this right now yeah
like look how big the explosion needs to
be to send you flying yeah and you think
little boy's gonna do that no no little
boy is not meant for that little boy
should be like reserved for toasting
marshmallows or something yeah or like
like a wizard showing you a small trick
you know
the northmen brutal Viking Epic period
drama this movie should have pleased me
but I went to see it and I was very
underwhelmed let's just start with like
what should be like a tent pool epic
One-Shot action with a brutal Viking
combat
oh yeah he caught it bye-bye found him
perfect right but other than enough one
shot long battle scene fits your you
know immersive Viking experience some
Dynamic camera motion constant
foreground wipes what says one shot more
than a constant four Crown type what's
this one shot more than a foreground boy
it's ambitious like I see what they're
going for they're trying to get that
real big movie look you know
yeah
I know I know yeah
I'm sorry man I'm sorry
dude the world's longest program like
the world's longest foreground wife I
know
oh my God
it's a verb now is there one more I
can't remember death by you are yeah
and they got the Vibes yeah I know it's
beautiful but I know how you felt now
Sam yeah yeah yeah like it's like yeah
the movie delivers 100 on Vibes but it's
like all right we're trying to do that
one shot Mega Action scene thing but
they're constantly doing the foreground
wipe trick because one takes can have a
feeling of realness but the question you
ask yourself as a director is is the
impact of the one take more important
than what I lose by not being able to
sculpt each moment and have the options
to cut and be able to get each moment in
the elevated version of what it could
actually do yeah I think it's super fair
you sacrifice the language of filmmaking
for potentially a potential level of
immersion let's say you have the shot
and there's just you got to make it
cooler and here's some really cheap VFX
that could have been done to this scene
just Spruce it up smoke plumes in the
background
a little bit more blood people running
around some torches maybe having more
debris fly across the back of the screen
it's just like get more things happening
but at the end of the day you are
following the main character and he does
just kind of go like this yeah yeah yeah
I don't know yeah yeah maybe don't
listen to my advice
this is like the final epic fight scene
this one's interesting too the VFX
that's in the scene in my opinion is is
very very funny
they're nude by the way I forgot to
mention that I will say fighting naked
does increase the fear like the
intensity of it just like we said
explosions smoke it's hard to control
but with VFX you can tell it exactly
where to go and where better than to
cover genitals during a nude fight scene
oh it kicks up whenever you see the
profile oh there it is yeah he's just
smoking right around them
let's see I don't know why this is so
funny to me maybe it's because like okay
so light sources you're drawn to them
genitals you're drawn to them like the
eye is drawn to these things and when
you put something in front of it you're
forced to look at it the really funny
thing is like as a whole the scene looks
amazing yeah the effects are amazing the
snow tiger is amazing yeah the tracking
and calming of the lava is really good
it's super cool it's the fact that the
smoke decides to conveniently Place
itself in just the right spot that makes
it almost extra funny because of how
good the effects are done exactly
exactly exactly and also it's like it's
like Eastern Promises there's there's a
nude fight scene a knife fight in a bath
house and it's just like yep there's
there's this there's his uh Franken
beans
you know there's not like they kind of
cut around and it's a fast scene but
it's not like it's hidden so to speak
and for this you're like oh immersive
Viking I picked like I can see some
nudity like I'm okay I'm prepared to see
the Franken beans
but like when that like little smoke
element just kind of conveniently
travels over it's just like it feels
like a lack of commitment yeah
a lack of commitment is one way to put
it don't get me started on the story
you want to see Sam get started on the
story go to quarterdigital.com we'll
have it in the Extended Cut
yeah
y'all might remember a little show
called Westworld oh yeah they have
robots in fact they show the very first
robot he ever built in the very first
episode the way they make that robot do
his thing
it's special let's take a look you put
yourself away again won't you Bill
that is so cool it's so cool he moves
like a little robot he has like a
Pirates of the Caribbean yeah the
animatronic like staggered motion I love
the way the mouth animates that's so
cool yeah it's such a nice little subtle
touch it's one of those things too where
it feels like there's like tricky
compositing or something going on but
ultimately if you watch it and you're
like is that just like a really cool
like break dancer guy in makeup who's
just been like trained to move like that
they're keeping the camera motion
everything's maintaining authenticity
there so it doesn't feel like it's a
time remapping thing with Roto or are
they using that as like an additional
element to further like cement the
stopping and the starting again and he's
just like really good at animating
because I know there are some dancers
who can do that so stinking well but not
not like that not like that not like
that independently and perfectly like
that so I do actually know how it's done
I looked at it up and did some research
here the actor himself Michael wincott
did not do any break dancing he moved
smoothly and normally he still gave the
full performance the way they did it is
actually super simple it's just a lot of
hard work it is just timer mapping so
you know if he moves his arm in a smooth
smooth Arc you can go like
but the thing is when you do your timer
mapping it applies to everything right
so they're just going in and cutting out
just his arm and then putting his arm on
its own timely map they're cutting out
his face or his lips and doing just
their lips on their own time remap
they're even like projecting him
sometimes and hitting him out and then
putting the new guy with all the time
remappings back in for the camera track
shots to keep it moving correctly that's
cool so I wonder they got clean plates
of the same motion I wonder if it was
probably wasn't motion control but
probably not motion control but they
probably used clean plates or just you
know tracked it in and the way he
freezes here is such a good Testament to
like how we pick up on subtleties like
right here boom Oh that hits us it's not
just it doesn't just go to a freeze
frame like we have these like innate
senses right we can tell it didn't just
go to a freeze frame he froze and
layering up the different parts to his
such a great touch yeah everything like
kind of locks in Cosa VFX is the company
that does section base here in La I mean
we just manipulate real footage like
this it's so convincing and so powerful
and so subtle there's no crazy 3D models
happening or anything and it just
grounds you so much more in the idea of
these things being real you know like
every little touch you can to further
immerse yourself into something like
this is is time well spent if you have
any ideas for films or shows or VFX we
should look at let us know in the
comments below and if you don't that's
okay because I want to do the Green
Knight
if you've seen the Green Knight let me
know what scene should we take a look at
it's pretty cool movie hey everyone
welcome back to another episode of
producers react to incredible episode
sponsors Dylan are you excited about
that oh my gosh uh so have you been
waiting for this this is something I've
been wanting to watch for a very long
time so I'm very excited to Jump Right
In and yeah and see what's happening
it's going to be phenomenal let's just
jump into it let's just jump in
oh look at how white those shoes are
look that guy's got a hat on she's got a
coat on they're probably experiencing a
little nice crisp fall weather here
through their patented Diamond text
material they're going to keep your feet
warm in the fall and winter and cool in
the summer I mean it's as easy as that
look at them having a good old time
what
[ __ ] water
look not a not a drop of water is gonna
end up on her foot because bessies are
100 water I did I read that online and
so when you take your shoe off the sock
is completely dry right snow sleet rain
whatever mud mud puddles and don't worry
because once your vesses are dirty you
can just wash them off throw them in the
water put them in the sink hose them
down yeah betsies are 100 vegan they
have no animal byproducts in the shoe
and they use less material during the
knitting process meaning that they're
also made more efficiently yeah but my
favorite part The Outfits there's so
many different types of vestes I mean
you can see it right here it doesn't
matter what you're wearing there's a
messy shoe mint for you going on a hot
date bam issue meant for you
achievement for you I mean we started
this we're thinking that we were going
to do a bunch of different Integrations
but it turns out this is the only one
for this episode so huge thanks to
bestie for sponsoring and if you're
interested in getting 25 off every pair
of bessies that you buy head on over to
bessie.com or just click the link in the
description below either one right they
both work the same you get 25 off either
way yeah there's no this is not like an
ore thing it's a and thing yeah all
right well thanks for watching and now
let's get back to today's sponsor VFX
artists react
say yesterday
those are some fantastic Clips I feel
like I learned a lot and I mean
revisiting Westworld what a great show
Corridor digital.com right now is piping
hot we got more crew cuts we got son of
a ducks in season two we got the
extended episodes up there we got Sam's
story time for Northman Sam's Club yeah
they're so great you should definitely
check it out I wish we could have
watched more explosion Clips I know you
had to cut us off it makes sense if you
wish we would have never stopped playing
sweet explosion clips and also felt like
you're learning something while watching
them check out tomorrow's video It's All
About explosions see you there